Shakira unexpectedly cancelled two big
shows recently and now we may know why
the singer took to Instagram on Tuesday
to let fans know that her son sasha was
sick
Shakira shared this adorable pic with
her 21 month old boy writing thanks for
all the messages you sent for Sasha
while he was sick everything is under
control now and he's back to his
cheerful self et has reached out to
Shakira's rep so I gotta say that was
very nice to see was it hands-on mom and
be part of it like thank you it's my new
row in February the hips don't lie
singer opened up to et's Cameron
Mathison about making her two boys her
number one priority it's amazing it's
really fun and also the most difficult
one I've ever undertaken in my life yeah
yeah it really is when I see other model
other mothers I they're right here in my
hearings there really are is so it's
such an admirable job especially people
who don't have any help we also try to
live a normal life we try to bring
normalcy to the lives of our kids
because we think that that's so
important